The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
shall we get started?
So, today-- well, before I
get started-started-- so,
let me open up to questions.
Do y'all have questions
from the last lecture,
where we finished
off angular momentum?
Or really anything
up to the last exam?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, what exactly
happens with the half l states?
PROFESSOR: Ha, ha, ha!
What happens with
the half l states?
OK, great question!
So, we're gonna talk about
that in some detail in a couple
of weeks, but let me
give you a quick preview.
So, remember that when we
studied the commutation
relations, Lx, Ly
is i h bar Lz .
Without using the representation
in terms of derivatives,
with respect to a
coordinate, without using
the representations, in terms
of translations and rotations
along the sphere, right?
When we just used the
commutation relations,
and nothing else,
what we found was
that the states corresponding
to these guys, came in a tower,
with either one state--
corresponding to little l
equals 0-- or two
states-- with l
equals 1/2-- or three
states-- with little l equals
1-- or four states-- with l
equals 3/2-- and so on, and so
forth.
And we quickly
deduced that it is
impossible to represent the
half integer states with a wave
function which
represents a probability
distribution on a sphere.
We observed that
that was impossible.
And the reason is, if
you did so, then when
you take that wave
function, if you
rotate by 2pi--
in any direction--
if you rotate by 2pi the
wave function comes back
to minus itself.
But the wave function
has to be equal to itself
at that same point.
The value of the wave
function at some point,
is equal to the wave
function at some point.
That means the value
of the wave function
must be equal to minus itself.
That means it must be zero0.
So, you can't write
a wave function--
which is a probability
distribution on a sphere--
if the wave function has
to be equal to minus itself
at any given point.
So, this is a strange thing.
And we sort of said, well, look,
these are some other beasts.
But the question is,
look, these furnish
perfectly reasonable
towers of states respecting
these commutation relations.
So, are they just wrong?
Are they just meaningless?
And what we're going to
discover is the following--
and this is really gonna go
back to the very first lecture,
and so, we'll do
this in more detail,
but I'm going to quickly
tell you-- imagine
take a magnet, a
little, tiny bar magnet.
In fact, well, imagine you
take a little bar magnet
with some little
magnetization, and you send it
through a region that has a
gradient for magnetic field.
If there's a gradient-- so
you know that a magnet wants
to anti-align with
the nearby magnet,
north-south wants to
go to south-north.
So, you can't put a
force on the magnet,
but if you have a gradient
of a magnetic field,
then one end a dipole--
one end of your magnet--
can feel a stronger effective
torque then the other guy.
And you can get a net force.
So, you can get a net force.
The important thing
here, is that if you
have a magnetic field which
has a gradient, so that you've
got some large B, here, and
some smaller B, here, then
you can get a force.
And that force is going
to be proportional to how
big your magnet is.
But it's also going
to be proportional
to the magnetic field.
And if the force is proportional
to the strength of your magnet,
then how far-- if you send
this magnet through a region,
it'll get deflected in one
direction or the other--
and how far it gets
deflected is determined
by how big of a magnet
you sent through.
You send in a bigger
magnet, it deflects more.
Everyone cool with that?
OK, here's a funny thing.
So, that's fact one.
Fact two, suppose I
have a system which
is a charged particle
moving in a circular orbit.
OK?
A charged particle moving
in a circular orbit.
Or better yet, well,
better yet, imaging
you have a sphere--
this is a better model--
imagine you have a sphere of
uniform charge distribution.
OK?
A little gelatinous sphere of
uniform charge distribution,
and you make it rotate, OK?
So, that's charged, that's
moving, forming a current.
And that current
generates a magnetic field
along the axis of
rotation, right?
Right hand rule.
So, if you have a charged
sphere, and it's rotating,
you get a magnetic moment.
And how big is the
magnetic moment,
it's proportional
to the rotation,
to the angular momentum, OK?
So, you determine that,
for a charged sphere here
which is rotating
with angular momentum,
let's say, l, has a
magnetic moment which
is proportional to l.
OK?
So, let's put this together.
Imagine we take
a charged sphere,
we send it rotating with
same angular momentum,
we send it through
a field gradient,
a gradient for magnetic field.
What we'll see is we can
measure that angular momentum
by measuring the deflection.
Because the bigger
the angular momentum,
the bigger the magnetic
moment, but the
bigger the magnetic moment,
the bigger the deflection.
Cool?
So, now here's the
cool experiment.
Take an electron.
And electron has some charge.
Is it a little,
point-like thing?
Is it a little sphere?
Is it, you know-- Let's not
ask that question just yet.
It's an electron.
The thing you get by ripping a
negative charge off a hydrogen
atom.
So, take your
electron and send it
through a magnetic
field gradient.
Why would you do this?
Because you want to
measure the angular
momentum of this electron.
You want to see whether the
electron is a little rotating
thing or not.
So, you send it through this
magnetic field gradient,
and if it gets
deflected, you will
have measured the
magnetic moment.
And if you have measured
the magnetic moment,
you'll have measured
the angular momentum.
OK?
Here's the funny thing, if
the electron weren't rotating,
it would just go
straight through, right?
It would have no
angular momentum,
and it would have
no magnetic moment,
and thus it would not reflect.
Yeah?
If it's rotating,
it's gonna deflect.
Here's the experiment we do.
And here's the
experimental results.
The experimental results
are every electron
that gets sent through bends.
And it either bends
up a fixed amount,
or it bends down a fixed amount.
It never bends more,
it never bends less,
and it certainly
never been zero.
In fact, it always makes
two spots on the screen.
OK?
Always makes two spots.
It never hits the middle.
No matter how you
build this experiment,
no matter how you rotate
it, no matter what you do,
it always hits one of two spots.
What that tells you is,
the angular momentum--
rather the magnetic moment--
can only take one of two values.
But the angular momentum is just
some geometric constant times
the angular momentum.
So, the angular
momentum must take
one of two possible values.
Everyone cool with that?
So, from this experiment--
glorified as the Stern Gerlach
Experiment-- from
this experiment,
we discover that the
angular momentum, Lz,
takes one of two values.
L, along whatever
direction we're
measuring-- but let's say in
the z direction-- Lz takes
one of two values, plus
some constant and, you know,
plus h bar upon 2, or
minus h bar upon 2.
And you just do
this measurement.
But what this tells
us is, which state?
Which tower?
Which set of states describe
an electron in this apparatus?
L equals 1/2.
But wait, we started
off by talking
about the rotation
of a charged sphere,
and deducing that the magnetic
moment must be proportional
to the angular momentum.
And what we've
just discovered is
that this angular momentum-- the
only sensible angular momentum,
here-- is the two
state tower, which
can't be represented in terms
of rotations on a sphere.
Yeah?
What we've learned
from this experiment
is that electrons carry a
form of angular momentum,
demonstrably.
Which is one of these angular
momentum 1/2 states, which
never doesn't rotate, right?
It always carries
some angular momentum.
However, it can't be
expressed in terms
of rotation of some
spherical electron.
It has nothing to
do with rotations.
If it did, we'd get
this nonsensical thing
of the wave function
identically vanishes.
So, there's some other
form of angular momentum--
a totally different form of
angular momentum-- at least
for electrons.
Which, again, has the
magnetic moment proportional
to this angular momentum
with some coefficient, which
I'll call mu0.
But I don't want to call
it L, because L we usually
use for rotational
angular momentum.
This is a different form
of angular momentum, which
is purely half integer,
and we call that spin.
And the spin satisfies
exactly the same commutation
relations-- it's a vector-- Sx
with Sy is equal to ih bar Sz.
So, it's like an angular
momentum in every possible way,
except it cannot be represented.
Sz does not have
any representation,
in terms of h bar
upon i [INAUDIBLE].
It is not related to a rotation.
It's an intrinsic form
of angular momentum.
An electron just has it.
So, at this point, you
ask me, look, what do you
mean an electron just has it?
And my answer to
that question is,
if you send an electron through
a Stern Gerlach Apparatus,
it always hits one of two spots.
And that's it, right?
It's an experimental fact.
And this is how we describe
that experimental fact.
And the legacy of these
little L equals 1/2 states,
is that they represent an
internal form of angular
momentum that only exists
quantum mechanically, that you
would have never
noticed classically.
That was a very
long answer to what
was initially a simple question.
But we'll come back and
do this in more detail,
this was just a quick intro.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, for
L equals 3/2, does
that mean that there's
4 values of spins?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that means there's
[? 4 ?] values of spins.
And so there are
plenty of particles
in the real world that
have L equals 3/2.
They're not fundamental
particles, as far as we know.
There are particles a nuclear
physics that carry spin 3/2.
There are all sorts of
nuclei that carry spin 3/2,
but we don't know of a
fundamental particle.
If super symmetry
is true, then there
must be a particle
called a gravitino, which
would be fundamental, and would
have spin 3/2, and four states,
but that hasn't
been observed, yet.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Was the
[? latter of ?]
seemingly nonsensical states
discovered first, and then
the experiment explain it,
or was it the experiment--
PROFESSOR: Oh, no!
Oh, that's a great question.
We'll come back the
that at end of today.
So today, we're gonna do
hydrogen, among other things.
Although, I've taken so
long talking about this,
we might be a little slow.
We'll talk about that
a little more when
we talk about hydrogen, but
it was observed and deduced
from experiment before
it was understood
that there was such
a physical quantity.
However, the observation that
this commutation relation
led to towers of
states with this
pre-existed as a
mathematical statement.
So, that was a
mathematical observation
from long previously, and it
has a beautiful algebraic story,
and all sort of
nice things, but it
hadn't been connected
to the physics.
And so, the observation
that the electron
must carry some intrinsic
form of angular momentum
with one of two values,
neither of which is 0,
was actually an
experimental observation--
quasi-experimental observation--
long before it was understood
exactly how to
connect this stuff.
AUDIENCE: So it wasn't--?
PROFESSOR: I shouldn't say
long, it was like within months,
but whatever.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: The intent of the
experiment wasn't to solve--
AUDIENCE: No, no.
The experiment was this--
there are the spectrum-- Well,
I'll tell you what the
experiment was in a minute.
OK, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Z has
to be plus or minus 1/2.
What fixes the direction
in the Z direction?
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
In this experiment,
the thing that
fixed the fact that
I was probing Lz
is that I made the
magnetic field have
a gradient in the Z direction.
So, what I was sensitive to,
since the force is actually
proportionally to mu dot
B-- or, really, mu dot
the gradient of B,
so, we'll do this
in more detail later-- the
direction of the gradient
selects out which component
of the angular momentum
we're looking at.
So, in this experiment, I'm
measuring the angular momentum
along this axis-- which
for fun, I'll call Z,
I could've called it
X-- what I discover
is the angular momentum
along this axis
must take one of two values.
But, the universe is
rotationally invariant.
So, it can't possibly
matter whether I
had done the experiment
in this direction,
or done the experiment in this
direction, what that tells
you is, in any direction
if I measure the angular
momentum of the electron
along that direction,
I will discover that it
takes one of two values.
This is also true of
the L equals 1 states.
Lz takes one of three values.
What about Lx?
Lx also takes one of three
values, those three values.
Is is every system in a
state corresponding to one
of those particular values?
No, it could be in
a superposition.
But the eigenvalues, are
these three eigenvalues,
regardless of whether
it's Lx, or Ly, or Lz.
OK, it's a good thing
to meditate upon.
Anything else?
One more.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
last problem [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Indeed.
Indeed.
OK.
Since some people haven't taken
the-- there will be a conflict
exam later today, so I'm not
going to discuss the exam yet.
But, very good observation,
and not an accident.
OK, so, today we launch into 3D.
We ditch our
tricked-out tricycle,
and we're gonna talk about
real, physical systems in three
dimensions.
And as we'll discover, it's
basically the same as in one
dimension, we just have to
write down more symbols.
But the content is all the same.
So, this will make
obvious the reason
we worked with 1D
up until now, which
is that there's
not a heck of a lot
more to be gained for
the basic principles,
but it's a lot more knowing
to write down the expressions.
So, the first thing
I wanted to do
is write down the
Laplacian in three
dimensions in
spherical coordinates--
And that is a beautiful abuse
of notation-- in spherical
coordinates.
And I want to note
a couple of things.
So, first off, this
Laplacian, this
can be written in the following
form, 1 over r dr r quantity
squared.
OK, that's going to be very
useful for us-- trust me
on this one-- this is also
known as 1 over r dr squared r.
And this, if you look
back at your notes,
this is nothing other
than L squared--
except for the factor of h bar
upon i-- but if it's squared,
it's minus 1 upon h bar squared.
OK, so this horrible
angular derivative,
is nothing but L squared.
OK, and you should remember
the [? dd ?] thetas,
and there are these
funny sines and cosines.
But just go back and
compare your notes.
So, this is an observation
that the Laplacian
in three dimensions and
spherical coordinates
takes this simple form.
A simple radial
derivative, which
is two terms if you write it
out linearly in this fashion,
and one term if you
write it this way,
which is going to turn
out to be useful for us.
And the angular part
can be written as 1
over r squared, times the
angular momentum squared
with a minus 1
over h bar squared.
OK?
So, in just to check,
remember that Lz
is equal to h bar upon i d phi.
So, Lz squared is going to be
equal to minus h bar squared
d phi squared.
And you can see that that's
one contribution to this beast.
But, actually, let me-- I'm
gonna commit a capital sin
and erase what I just
wrote, because I don't
want it to distract you-- OK.
So, with that
useful observation,
I want to think about
central potentials.
I want to think about systems
in 3D, which are spherically
symmetric, because this is
going to be a particularly
simple class of
systems, and it's also
particularly physical.
Simple things like a
harmonic oscillator
In three dimensions, which we
solved in Cartesian coordinates
earlier, we're
gonna solve later,
in spherical coordinates.
Things like the isotropic
harmonic oscillator, things
like hydrogen, where the system
is rotationally independent,
the force of the potential only
depends on the radial distance,
all share a bunch of
common properties,
and I want to explore those.
And along the way, we'll solve
a toy model for hydrogen.
So, the energy for this
is p squared upon 2m,
plus a potential, which
is a function only
of the radial distance.
But now, p squared is equal
to minus h bar squared
times the gradient squared.
But this is gonna be equal to,
from the first term, minus h
bar squared-- let me just
write this out-- times
r dr squared r.
And then from this term, plus
minus h bar squared times minus
1 over h bar squared
[? to L squared ?] [? over ?] r
squared, plus L
squared over r squared.
So, the energy can be
written in a nice form.
This is minus h bar
squared, 1 upon r dr
squared r-- whoops,
sorry-- upon 2m,
because it's p squared upon 2m.
And from the second term, L
squared over r squared upon 2m
plus 1 over 2mr squared
L squared plus u of r.
OK, and this is the energy
operator when the system is
rotational invariant in
spherical coordinates.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is
that an equals sign or minus?
PROFESSOR: This?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's
an equals sign.
So, sorry.
This is just quick algebra.
So, it's useful to know it.
So, consider the following
thing, 1 over r dr r.
Why would you ever care
about such a thing?
Well, let's square it.
OK, because I did there.
So, what is this equal to?
Well, this is 1 over r dr r.
1 over r dr r.
These guys cancel, right?
1 over r times dr. So, this is
equal to 1 over r dr squared r.
But, why is this equal to dr
squared plus 2 over r times dr?
And the answer is,
they're operators.
And so, you should ask
how they act on functions.
So, let's ask how
they act on function.
So, dr squared plus 2 over
r dr times a function--
acting as a function-- is
equal to f prime prime--
if this is a function of
r-- plus 2 over r f prime.
On the other hand, 1 over r dr
squared r, acting on f of r,
well, these derivatives can
hit either the r of the f.
So, there's going to be a term
where both derivatives hit
f, in which case the rs cancel,
and I get f prime prime.
There's gonna be two terms
where one of the d's hits
this, one of the d's hits this,
then there's the other term.
So, there're two
terms of that form.
On d hits the r and gives
me one, one d hits the f
and gives me f prime.
And then there's an overall 1
over r plus 2 over r f prime.
And then there's a term
were two d's hit the r,
but if two d's hit
the r, that's 0.
So, that's it.
So, these guys are
equal to each other.
So, why is this a
particularly useful form?
We'll see that in just a minute.
So, I'm cheating a little
bit by just writing this
out and saying, this is
going to be a useful form.
But trust me, it's going
to be a useful form.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we need to find d
squared [INAUDIBLE] dr squared
r.
Isn't that supposed
to be 1 over r?
PROFESSOR: Oh shoot!
Yes, that's supposed to
be one of our-- Thank you.
Thank you!
Yes, over r.
Thank you.
Yes, thank you for
that typo correction.
Excellent.
Thanks OK.
So, anytime we
have a system which
is rotationally invariant--
whose potential is rotationally
invariant-- we can
write the energy
operator in this fashion.
And now, you see
something really lovely,
which is that this
only depends on r,
this only depends
on r, this depends
on the angular
coordinates, but only
insofar as it
depends on L squared.
So, if we want to find
the eigenfunctions of E,
our life is going to
be a lot easier if we
work in eigenfunctions
of L. Because that's
gonna make this one [? Ex ?]
on an eigenfunction of L,
this is just going
to become a constant.
So, now you have to answer
the question, well, can we?
Can we find functions which are
eigenfunctions of E and of L,
simultaneously?
And so, the answer
to that question
is, well, compute
the commutator.
So, do these guys commute?
In particular, of L squared.
And, well, does L commute
with the derivative
with respect to r, L squared?
Yeah, because L only depends
on angular derivatives.
It doesn't have any rs in it.
And the rs don't care about
the angular variables,
so they commute.
What about with this term?
Well, L squared trivially
commutes with itself
and, again, r doesn't matter.
And ditto, r and
L squared commute.
So, this is 0.
These commute.
So, we can find
common eigenbasis.
We can find a basis
of functions which
are eigenfunctions both
of E and of L squared.
So, now we use separation.
In particular, if we
want to find a function--
an eigenfunction-- of
the energy operator,
E phi E is equal
to E phi E, it's
going to simplify our
lives if we also let phi
be an eigenfunction
of the L squared.
But we know what the
eigenfunctions of L squared
are.
E phi E is equal to--
let me write this--
of r will then be equal
to little phi of r
times yLm of theta and phi.
Now, quickly, because these
are the eigenfunctions of the L
squared operator.
Quick, is little l an
integer or a half integer?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURS] Integer.
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURS]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because we're
working with rotational angular
momentum, right?
And it only makes sense to talk
about integer values of little
l when we have gradients on
a sphere-- when we're talking
about rotations-- on a
spherical coordinates, OK?
So, little l has
to be an integer.
And from this point forward in
the class, any time I write l,
I'll be talking about the
rotational angular momentum
corresponding to integer values.
And when I'm talking about
the half integer values,
I'll write down s, OK?
So, let's use this
separation of variables.
And what does that give us?
Well, l squared
acting on yLm gives us
h bar squared lL plus 1.
So, this tells us that
E, acting on phi E,
takes a particularly
simple form.
If phi E is proportional
to a spherical harmonic,
then this is gonna take the form
minus h bar squared upon 2m 1
over r dr squared r plus
1 over 2mr squared l
squared-- but l squared
acting on the yLm
gives us-- h bar
squared lL plus 1, which
is just a constant over r
squared plus u of r phi E.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] yLm1 and yLm2?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So, can we consider
superpositions of these guys?
Absolutely, we can.
However, we're using separation.
So, we're gonna look
at a single term,
and then after
constructing solutions
with a single
eigenfunction of L squared,
we can then write down
arbitrary superposition of them,
and generate a complete
basis of states.
General statement about
separation of variables.
Other questions?
OK.
So, here's the resulting
energy eigenvalue equation.
But notice that it's
now, really nice.
This is purely a function of r.
We've removed all of
the angular dependence
by making this
proportional to yLm.
So, this has a little phi yLm,
and this has a little phi yLm,
and nothing depends
on the little phi.
Nothing depends on the yLm--
on the angular variables--
I can make this phi of r.
And if I want to make this the
energy eigenvalue equation,
instead of just the action
of the energy operator,
that is now my energy
eigenvalue equation.
This is the result of acting on
phi with the energy operator,
and this is the
energy eigenvalue.
Cool?
So, the upside here is that when
we have a central potential,
when the system is
rotationally invariant,
the potential energy is
invariant under rotations,
then the energy commutes with
the angular momentum squared.
And so, we can find
common eigenfunctions.
When we use separation
of variable,
the resulting energy
eigenvalue equation
becomes nothing but a 1D energy
eigenvalue equation, right?
This is just a 1D equation.
Now, you might look at this
and say, well, it's not quite
a 1D equation, because if
this were a 1D equation,
we wouldn't have this funny
1 over r, and this funny r,
right?
It's not exactly what
we would have got.
It's got the minus h bar
squareds upon 2m-- whoops,
and there's, yeah, OK-- it's got
this funny h bar squareds upon
2m, and it's got these
1 over-- or sorry,--
it's got the correct h
bar squareds upon 2m,
but it's got this
funny r and 1 over r.
So, let's get rid of that.
Let's just quickly dispense
with that funny set of r.
And this comes back
to the sneaky trick
I was referring to earlier,
of writing this expression.
So, rather than
writing this out,
it's convenient to
write it in this form.
Let's see why.
So, if we have the E phi of r
is equal to minus h bar squared
upon 2m, 1 over r d squared
r r, plus-- and now,
what I'm gonna write is-- look,
this is our potential, u of r.
This is some silly,
radial-dependent thing.
I'm gonna write these
two terms together,
rather than writing them over,
and over, and over again, I'm
going to write them together,
and call them V effective.
Plus V effective of r, where V
effective is just these guys,
V effective.
Which has a contribution
from the original potential,
and from the angular
momentum, which,
notice the sign is
plus 1 over r squared.
So, the potential gets really
large as you get to the origin.
Phi of r.
So, this r is annoying, and
this 1 over r is annoying,
but there's a nice
way to get rid of it.
Let phi of r-- well, this r,
we want to get rid of-- so,
let phi of r equals
1 over r u of r.
OK, then 1 over r squared--
or sorry, 1 over r-- dr
squared r phi is equal to 1
over r dr squared r times 1
over r times u, which is just u.
But meanwhile, V on
phi is equal to-- well,
V doesn't have
any r derivatives,
it's just a function-- so, V
of phi is just 1 over r V on u.
So, this equation
becomes E on u,
because this also
picks up a 1 over r,
is equal to minus h bar
squared upon 2m dr squared
plus V effective of r u of r.
And this is exactly the
energy eigenvalue equation
for a 1D problem with
the following potential.
The potential, V effective of r,
does the following two things--
whoops, don't want to
draw it that way-- suppose
we have a potential which
is the Coulomb potential.
So, let's say, u is equal
to minus E squared upon r.
Just as an example.
So, here's r, here
is V effective.
So, u first, so
there's u-- u of r,
so let me draw this-- V
has another term, which
is h bar squared lL
plus 1 over 2mr squared.
This is for any
given value of l.
This is a constant over r
squared, with a plus sign.
So, that's something
that looks like this.
This is falling
off like 1 over r,
this is falling off
like 1 over r squared.
So, it falls off more rapidly.
And finally, can r be negative?
No.
It's defined from 0 to infinity.
So, that's like having
an infinite potential
for negative r.
So, our effective
potential is the sum
of these contributions--
wish I had
colored chalk-- the sum
of these contributions
is going to look like this.
So, that's my V effective.
This is my Ll plus 1 [INAUDIBLE]
squared over 2mr squared.
And this is my u of r.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
OK, so this is u of r,
the original potential.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
This is 1 over L squared-- or
sorry-- lL 1 over 2mr squared.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh shoot!
Oh, I'm sorry!
I'm terribly sorry!
I've abused the
notation terribly.
Let's-- Oh!
This is-- Crap!
Sorry.
This is standard notation.
And in text, when I
write this by hand,
the potential is a big
U, and the wave function
is a little u.
So, let this be a little u.
OK, this is my little
u and so, now I'm
gonna have to-- oh
jeez, this is horrible,
sorry-- this is the
potential, capital U
with a bar underneath it.
OK, seriously, so
there's capital U
with a bar underneath it.
And here's V, which is
gonna make my life easier,
and this is the capital U
with the bar underneath it.
Capital U with the
bar underneath it.
Oh, I'm really sorry,
I did not realize
how confusing that would be.
OK, is everyone happy with that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Which one?
AUDIENCE: Middle.
Middle.
PROFESSOR: Middle.
AUDIENCE: Up, up.
Right there!
Up!
There.
PROFESSOR: Where?
AUDIENCE: To the right.
[CHATTER] Near the eraser mark.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So, these
are the wave function.
AUDIENCE: I know.
PROFESSOR: That's
the wave function.
That is V.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: Wait, if I
erased, how can I correct it?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER] There!
PROFESSOR: Excellent, so
the thing that isn't here,
would have a bar under it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, sorry!
Ah!
You wouldn't think
it would be so hard.
OK, good.
And this is not [? related ?]
to the wave function.
OK, god, oh!
That's horrible!
Sorry guys, that
notation is not obvious.
My apologies.
Oh, there's a better
way to do this.
OK, here's the better
Instead of calling the
potential-- I'm sorry,
your notes are getting
destroyed now-- so instead
of calling potential capital U,
let's just call this V. Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER] No!
PROFESSOR: And then
we have V effective.
No, no.
This is good.
We can be careful about this.
So, this is V. This
is V effective,
which has V plus the
angular momentum term.
Oh, good Lord!
This is V effective.
This is V. V phi [INAUDIBLE]
U. Good, this is V.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
There's no U--
PROFESSOR: There's
no U underline,
it's now just V, V effective.
Oh!
Good Lord!
OK, wow!
That was an
unnecessary confusion.
AUDIENCE: Top right.
PROFESSOR: Top right.
AUDIENCE: There is no bar.
[? PROFESSOR: Mu. ?]
AUDIENCE: Is that
V or V effective?
PROFESSOR: That's V.
Although, it would've
been just as true
as V effective.
So, we can write V effective.
It's true for both.
Because it's just
a function of r.
Oh, for the love of God!
OK.
Let's check our sanity,
and walk through the logic.
So, the logic here is, we
have some potential, it's
a function only of r, yeah?
As a consequence, since it
doesn't care about the angles,
we can write things in terms
of the spherical harmonics,
we can do separation
of variables.
Here's the energy
eigenvalue equation.
We discover that because we're
working in spherical harmonics,
the angular momentum term
becomes just a function of r,
with no other coefficients.
So, now we have a function
of r plus the potential V,
this looks like an effective
potential, V effective,
which is the sum
of these two terms.
So, there's that equation.
On the other hand,
this is tantalizingly
close to but not quite the
energy eigenvalue equation
for a 1D problem with this
potential, V effective.
To make it obvious that
it's, in fact, a 1D problem,
we do a change of variables,
phi goes to 1 over ru,
and then 1 upon r d
squared r phi becomes 1
over r d squared u,
and V effective phi
becomes 1 over r V effective u.
Plugging that together, gives us
this energy eigenvalue equation
for u, the effective wave
function, which is 1d problem.
So, we can use all
of our intuition
and all of our machinery
to solve this problem.
And now we have to
ask, what exactly
is the effective potential?
And the effective potential
has three contributions.
First, it has the
original V, secondly, it
has the angular
momentum term, which
is a constant over r
squared-- and here is
that, constant over r
squared-- and the sum of these
is the effective.
And this guy dominates
because it's 1 over r squared.
This dominates at small r,
and this dominates at large r
if it's 1 over r.
So, we get an
effective potential--
that I'll check-- there's
the effective potential.
And finally, the
third fact is that r
must be strictly positive,
so as a 1D problem,
that means it can't be
negative, it's gotta
have an infinite
potential on the left.
So, as an example, let's go
ahead and think more carefully
about specifically this problem,
about this Coulomb potential,
and this 1D effective potential.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where does
the 1 over r go?
PROFESSOR: Good.
So, remember the ddr
squared term gave us a 1
over r out front.
So, from this term, there
should be 1 over r, here.
From this term, there
should also be a 1 over r.
And from here, there
should be a 1 over r.
AUDIENCE: Ah!
PROFESSOR: So, then I'm
gonna cancel the 1 over r
by multiplying the
whole equation by r.
Yeah?
Sneaky, sneaky.
So, any time you see-- any
time, this is a general lesson--
anytime you see a
differential equation that
has this form-- two
derivatives, plus 1
over r a derivative--
you know you
can play some game like this.
If you see this, declare in your
mind a brief moment of triumph,
because you know what
technique to use.
You can do this sort of
rescaling by a power of r.
And more generally, if you have
a differential equation that
looks like-- let
me do this here--
if you have a differential
equation that looks something
like a derivative with respect
to r plus a constant over r
times phi, you know
how to solve this.
Let me say plus
dot, dot, dot phi.
You know how to solve this
because ddr plus c over r
means that phi, if there were
nothing else, equals zero.
If there were no other terms
here, then this would say,
ddr plus c over r
is phi, that means
when you take a derivative
it's like dividing by r
and multiplying by c.
That means that phi goes
like r to the minus c, right?
But if phi goes like
r to the minus c,
that's not the exact
solution to the equation,
but I can write phi is equal
to r to the minus c times u.
And then this equation
becomes ddr plus dot, dot,
dot u equals zero.
OK?
Very useful little
trick-- not really
a trick, It's just observation--
and this is the second order
version of the same thing.
Very useful things
to have in your back
pocket for moments of need.
OK?
So, let's pick up with this guy.
So, let me give you a
little name for this.
So, this term that comes
from the angular momentum
[? bit, ?] this originally came
from the kinetic energy, right?
It came from the
L squared over r,
which was from the
gradient squared energy.
This is a kinetic energy term.
Why is there a
kinetic energy term?
Well, what this is telling
you is that if you have some
angular momentum-- if little
l is not equal to 0---
then as you get closer
and closer to the origin,
the potential energy is
getting very, very large.
And this should make sense.
If you're spinning, and
you pull in your arms,
you have to do work, right?
You have to pull those guys in.
You speed up.
You're increasing
your kinetic energy
due to conservation of
angular momentum, right?
If you have
rotationally invariance,
as you bring in your hand you're
increasing the kinetic energy.
And so, this angular
momentum barrier
is just an expression of that.
It's just saying
that as you come
to smaller and smaller
radius, holding the angular
momentum fixed, your velocity--
your angular velocity-- must
increase-- your kinetic
energy must increase--
and we're calling
that a potential term
just because we can.
Because we've worked with
definite angular momentum, OK?
You should have done this in
classical mechanics as well.
Well, you should have done
it in classical mechanics.
So, this is called the
angular momentum barrier.
Quick question, classically,
if you take a charged particle
around in a Coulomb potential,
classically that system decays,
right?
Irradiates away energy.
Does the angular momentum
barrier save us from decaying?
Is that why hydrogen is stable?
No one wants to
stake a claim here?
Is hydrogen stable
because of conversation
of angular momentum?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Absolutely not, right?
So, first off, in your
first problems set,
when you did that
calculation, that particle
had angular momentum.
So, and if can radiate
that away through
electromagnetic interactions.
So, that didn't save us.
Angular momentum won't save us.
Another way to say this
is that we can construct--
and we just explicitly
see-- we can construct
a state with which
has little l equals 0.
In which case the
angular momentum barrier
is 0 over r squared,
because there's nothing.
Angular momentum barrier's not
what keeps you from decaying.
And the reason is that the
electron can radiate away
energy and angular
momentum, and so l
will decrease and decrease,
and can still fall down.
So, we still need
a reason for why
the hydrogen system, quantum
mechanically, is stable.
[? Why do ?] [? things exist? ?]
So, let's answer that question.
So, what I want to do
now is, I want to solve--
do I really want to do it
that way?-- well, actually,
before we do, let's consider
some last, general conditions.
General facts for
central potentials.
So, let's look at some general
facts for central potentials.
So, the first is, regardless of
what the [? bare ?] potential
was, just due to the
angular momentum barrier,
we have this 1 over r squared
behavior near the origin.
So, we can look at
this, we can ask, look,
what are the boundary
conditions at the origin?
What must be true of u
of r near the origin?
Near u of r-- or
sorry, near r goes
to zero-- what must
be true of u of r?
So, the right way to
ask this question is not
to look at this u of r, which is
not actually the wave function,
but to look at the
actual wave function,
phi sub E, which goes near r
equals 0, like u of r over r.
So, what should be true of u?
Can u diverge?
Is that physical?
Does u have to vanish?
Can it take a constant value?
So, I've given you a
hint by telling you
that I want to think about there
being an infinite potential,
but why?
Why is that the
right thing to do?
Well, imagine u of r went to a
constant value near the origin.
If u of r goes to a constant
value near the origin,
then the wave function
diverges near the origin.
That's maybe not so bad, maybe
it has a 1 over r singularity.
It's not totally obvious
that that's horrible.
What's so bad about having
a 1 over r behavior?
So, suppose u goes
to a constant.
So, phi goes to constant over r.
What's so bad about this?
So, let's look back
at the kinetic energy.
P is equal t--
the kinetic energy
is gonna be minus h bar squared
p squared-- so the energy is
going to go like, p
squared over 2md squared.
But here's an important fact, d
squared-- the Laplacian-- of 1
over r, well, it's
easy to see what
this is at a general point.
At a general point,
d squared has a term
that looks like 1
over rd squared r r.
So, 1 over rd squared
r on 1 over r.
Well, r times 1 over
r, that's just 1.
And this is 0, right?
So, the gradient squared
of 1 over r, is 0.
Except, can that possibly
be true at r equals 0?
No, because what's the
second derivative at 0?
As you approach the
origin from any direction,
the function is going like 1
over r, OK, so it's growing,
but it's growing
in every direction.
So, what's its first
derivative at the origin?
It's actually
ill-defined, because it
depends on the
direction you come in.
The first direction coming
in this way, the derivative
looks like it's becoming
this, from this direction it's
becoming this, it's
actually badly divergent.
So, what's the
second derivative?
Well, the second
derivative has to go
as you go across
this point, it's
telling you how the
first derivative changes.
But it changes from plus
infinity in this direction,
to plus infinity
in this direction.
That's badly singular.
So, this can't possibly be true,
what I just wrote down here.
And, in fact, d squared
on 1 over r-- and this
is a very good exercise
for recitation--
is equal to delta of r.
It's 0-- it's clearly 0 for r0
equals 0--- but at the origin,
it's divergent.
And it's divergent
in exactly the way
you need to get
the delta function.
OK, which is pretty awesome.
So, what that tells us is that
if we have a wave function that
goes like 1 over r, then the
energy contribution-- energy
acting on this wave
function-- gives us
a delta function at the origin.
So, unless you have
the potential, which
is a delta function
at the origin,
nothing will cancel this off.
You can't possibly satisfy the
energy eigenvalue equation.
So, u of r must go
to 0 at r goes to 0.
Because if it goes to a
constant-- any constant--
we've got a bad divergence
in the energy, yeah?
In particular, if we
calculate the energy,
we'll discover that the
energy is badly divergent.
It does become divergent if
we don't have u going to 0.
So, notice, by the way, as a
side note, that since phi goes
like, phi is equal
to u over r, that
means that phi
goes to a constant.
This is good, because
what this is telling
us is that the wave function--
So, truly, u is vanishing,
but the probability
density, which
is the wave function squared,
doesn't have to vanish.
That's about the
derivative of u,
as you approach the origin
from [? Lucatau's ?] Rule.
So, this is the first general
fact about central potential.
So, the next one-- and this
is really fun one-- good Lord!
Is that, note---
sorry, two more--
the energy depends
on l but not on m.
Just explicitly, in the
energy eigenvalue equation,
we have the angular
momentum showing up int
the effective
potential, little l.
But little m appears absolutely
nowhere except in our choice
of spherical harmonic.
For any different m--
and this was pointing out
before-- for any different m, we
would've got the same equation.
And that means that the energy
eigenvalue can depend on l,
but it can't depend on m, right?
So, that means for each m in
the allowed possible values, l,
l minus 1, [? i ?]
minus l-- and this
is 2l plus 1 possible
values-- for each
of these m's, the
energy is the same.
And I'll call this E sub
l, because the energy
can depend on l.
Why?
The degeneracy of E sub
L is equal to 2l plus 1.
Why?
Why do we have this degeneracy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
We get the degeneracies when
we have symmetries, right?
When we have a symmetry,
we get a degeneracy.
And so, here we
have a degeneracy.
And this degeneracy isn't
fixed by rotational invariance.
And why is this the right thing?
Rotational symmetry?
So why, did this give
us this degeneracy?
But what the rotational
degeneracy is saying is,
look, if you've got some
total angular momentum,
the energy can't possibly depend
on whether most of it's in Z,
or most of it's in X,
or most of it's and Y.
It can't possibly
depend on that,
but that's what
m is telling you.
M is just telling
you what fraction
is contained in a
particular direction.
So, rotational symmetry
immediately tells you this.
But there's a nice way to phrase
this, which of the following,
look, what is
rotational symmetry?
Rotational symmetry
is the statement
that the energy doesn't
care about rotations.
And in particular, it must
commute with Lx, and with Ly,
and with Lz.
So, this is
rotationally symmetry.
And I'm going to interpret
these in a nice way.
So, this guy tells me I can
find common eigenfunctions.
And, more to the point, a full
common eigenbasis of E and Lz.
Can I also find a common
eigenbasis of ELz and Ly?
Are there common
eigenvectors of ELz and Ly?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: No.
Are there common
eigenfunctions of Lz and Ly?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, because
they don't commute, right?
E commutes with each of these.
OK, so, I'm just
going to say, I'm
gonna pick a common
eigenbasis of E and Lz--
but I could've picked Lx,
or I could've picked Ly,
I'm just picking Lz because
that's our convention--
but what do these two--
Once I've chosen this--
I'm gonna work with a common
eigenbasis of E and Lz--
what do these two
commutators tell me?
These two commutators
tell me that E commutes
with Lx plus iLy and Lx
minus iLy, L plus/minus.
So, this tells you that if you
have an eigenfunctions of E,
and you act with a
raising operator,
you get another
eigenfunction of E.
And thus, we get our
2L plus 1 degeneracy,
because we can walk up and
down the tower using L plus
and L minus.
Cool?
OK.
So, this is a nice example
that when you have a symmetry
you get a degeneracy,
and vice versa.
OK.
So, let's do some examples of
using these central potentials.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Yeah
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's 0.
So, E with Lx is 0.
E with Ly-- So, are you
happy with that statement?
That E with Lx is 0?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Good.
OK, and so this 0 because
this is just Lx plus iOi.
So, E with Lx is
0, and E with Ly
is 0, so E commutes
with these guys.
And so, this is
like the statement
that L squared with L
plus/minus equals 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cool.
OK, so, let's do some examples.
So, the first example
is gonna be-- actually,
I'm going to skip this spherical
well example-- because it's
just not that interesting,
but it's in the notes,
and you really
need to look at it.
Oh hell, yes, I'm
going to do it.
OK, so, the spherical well.
So, I'm going to do it
in an abridged form,
and maybe it's a good
thing for recitation.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Thank you
recitation leader.
So, in this spherical
well, what's the potential?
So, here's v of r.
Not U bar, and not V
effective, just v or r.
And the potential is going to
be this, so, here's r equals 0.
And if it's a spherical infinite
well, then I'm gonna say,
the potential is infinite
outside of some distance, l.
OK?
And it's 0 inside.
So, what does this give us?
Well, in order to
solve the system,
we know that the
first thing we do
is we separate out
with yLms, and then
we re-scale by 1 over r
to get the function of u,
and we get this
equation, which is E on u
is equal to minus h bar
squared upon 2m dr squared
and plus v effective--
well, plus [? lL ?] plus 1--
over r squared with a
2m and an h bar squared.
And the potential is 0, inside.
So we can just write this.
So, if you just--
let me pull out
the h bar squareds over 2m--
it becomes minus [INAUDIBLE]
plus 1 over r squared.
So, this is not a terrible
differential equation.
And one can do some
good work to solve it,
but it's a harder
differential equation
than I want to spend the
time to study right now,
so I'm just going to consider
the case-- special case-- when
there's zero angular
momentum, little l equals 0.
So, in the special
case of a l equals 0,
E-- and I should
call this u sub l--
Eu sub 0 is equal to
h bar squared upon 2m.
And now, this term is gone--
the angular momentum barrier is
gone-- because there's
no angular momentum,
dr squared ul.
Which can be written
succinctly as ul-- or sorry,
u0-- prime prime, because
this is only a function of r.
So now, this is a
ridiculously easy equation.
We know how to solve
this equation, right?
This is saying that the
energy, a constant, times u
is two derivatives
times this constant.
So, u0 can be written as a
cosine of kx-- or sorry-- kr
plus b sine of kr, where h
bar squared k squared upon 2m
equals E. And I should
really call this E sub 0,
because it could depend
on little l, here.
So, there's our
momentary solution,
however, we have to satisfy
our boundary conditions, which
is that it's gotta
vanish at the origin,
but it's also gotta
vanish at the wall.
So, the boundary
conditions, u of 0
equals 0 tells us that a must
be equal to 0, and u of l
equals 0 tells us that, well,
if this is 0, we've just got B,
but sine of kr evaluated
at l, which is sine of kl,
must be equal to 0.
So, kl must be the 0 of
sine, must be n pi over--
must be equal to n
pi, a multiple of pi.
And so, this tells you
what the energy is.
So, this is just
like the 1D system.
It's just exactly like
when the 1D system.
So now, to finally
close this off.
What does this tell you
that the eigenfunctions are?
And let me do that here.
So, therefore, the wave
function phi sub E0 of r theta
and phi-- oh god, oh jesus,
this is so much easier
in [INAUDIBLE] so,
phi [INAUDIBLE]
0 of r theta and
phi is equal to y0m.
But what must m be?
0, because m goes from
plus L to minus L, 0.
I'm just [INAUDIBLE]
the argument.
Y00 times, not u of r,
times 1 over r times u.
1 over r times u of r.
But u of r is a constant
times sine of kr.
Sine of kr, but k is equal
to n pi over L. N pi over Lr.
And what's Y00?
It's a constant.
And so, there's an overall
normalization constant,
that I'll call n.
OK, so, we get that
our wave function
is 1 over r times
sine of n pi over Lr.
So, this looks bad.
There's a 1 over r.
Why is this not bad?
At the origin, why
is this not something
I should worry about it?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURS]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
sine is linear, first of all,
[INAUDIBLE] argument.
So, this goes like,
n pi over L times r.
That r cancels the 1 over r.
So, near the origin, this
goes like a constant.
Yeah?
So, u has to 0, but the
wave function doesn't.
Cool?
OK.
So, this is a very
nice more general story
for larger L, which I hope
you see in the recitation.
OK.
Questions on the spherical well?
The whole point
here-- Oh, yeah, go.
AUDIENCE: What do [INAUDIBLE]
generally [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's true.
So, good.
So, let me rephrase
the question,
and tell me if this
is the same question.
So, this is strange.
There's nothing special
about the origin.
So, why do I have
a 0 at the origin?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
It's true.
There's nothing special
about the origin,
except for two things.
One thing that's
special about the origin
is we're working
in a system which
has a rotational symmetry.
But rotational symmetry
is rotational symmetry
around some particular point.
So, there's always a special
central point anytime
you have a rotational symmetry.
It's the point fixed
by the rotations.
So, actually, the origin
is a special point here.
Second, saying that
little u has a 0
is not the same as saying that
the wave function has a 0.
Little u has a 0, but it
gets multiplied by 1 over r.
So, the wave function, in
fact, is non-zero, there.
So, the physical thing is
the probability distribution,
which is the [? norm ?]
squared of the wave function.
And it doesn't have
a 0 at the origin.
Does that satisfy?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, the origin is special when
you have a central potential.
That's where the
proton is, right?
Right, OK.
So, there is something
special about the origin.
Wow, that was a really
[? anti-caplarian ?] sort
of argument.
OK, so that's where
the proton-- so, there
is something special
about the origin,
and the wave function doesn't
vanish there, even if u does.
It may vanish there, but it
doesn't necessarily have to.
And we'll see that in a minute.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, what again, what's
the reasoning for saying that
the u of r has to vanish at
[? 0 instead ?] [? of L? ?]
PROFESSOR: Good.
The reason that u of r had
to vanish at the origin
is that if it doesn't
vanish at the origin,
then the wave function
diverges-- whoops,
phi goes to constant--
if u doesn't go to 0,
if it goes to any
constant, non-zero,
then the wave function diverges.
And if we calculate
the energy, we
get a delta function
at the origin.
So, there's an
infinite contribution
of energy at the origin.
That's not physical.
So, in order to get a
sensible wave function
with finite energies, we need
to have the u vanishes, because
of the 1 over u.
And the reason that we
said it had to vanish at l,
was because I was considering
this spherical well-- spherical
infinite well-- where
a particle is stuck
inside a region of
radius, capital L,
and that's just what
I mean by saying
I have an infinite potential.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
PROFESSOR: Cool?
Yeah.
Others?
OK.
So, with all that
done, we can now
do the hydrogen-- or
the Coulomb-- potential.
And I want to emphasize that
we often use the following
words when-- people often
use the following words when
solving this
problem-- we will now
solve the problem of hydrogen.
This is false.
I am not about to solve for
you the problem of hydrogen.
I am going to construct for
you a nice toy model, which
turns out to be an excellent
first pass at explaining
the properties observed in
hydrogen gases, their emission
spectra, and their physics.
This is a model.
It is a bad model.
It doesn't fit the data.
But it's pretty good.
And we'll be able
to improve it later.
OK?
So, it is the solution
of the Coulomb potential.
And what I want to
emphasize to you,
I cannot say this
strongly enough,
physics is a process of building
models that do a good job
of predicting.
And the better their
predictions, the better the
model.
But they're all wrong.
Every single model you ever
get from physics is wrong.
There are just some that
are less stupidly wrong.
Some are a better
approximation to the data, OK?
This is not hydrogen.
This is going to be our
first pass at hydrogen.
It's the Coulomb potential.
And the Coulomb potential,
V of r, is equal to minus e
squared over r.
This is what you
would get if you
had a classical particle with
infinite mass and charge plus
b.
And then another
particle over here,
with mass, little m,
and charge, minus e.
And you didn't pay
too much attention
to things like relativity,
or spin, or, you know,
lots of other things.
And you have no
background magnetic field,
or electric field,
and anything else.
And if these are point
particles, and-- All
of those things are
false that I just said.
But if all those
things were true,
in that imaginary universe, this
would be the salient problem
to solve.
So, let's solve it.
Now, are all those
things that I said
that were false-- the
proton's a point particle,
the proton is
infinitely massive,
there's no spin-- are those
preposterously stupid?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, they're
excellent approximations
in a lot of situations.
So, they're not crazy wrong.
They're just not
exactly correct.
I want to keep
this in your mind.
These are gonna be good
models, but they're not exact.
So, we're not solving
hydrogen, we're
gonna solve this idealized
Coulomb potential problem.
OK, so let's solve it.
So, if V is minus
e over r squared,
then the equation for the
rescaled wave function, u,
becomes minus h bar squared
upon 2mu prime prime
of r plus the effective
potential, which
is h bar squared
upon 2mll plus 1
over r squared minus e squared
over r u is equal to e sub l u.
So, there's the equation
we want to solve.
We've already used
separation of variables,
and we know that
the wave function
is this little u times
1 over r times yLm,
for some l and some m.
So, the first thing we
should do any time you're
solving an interesting problem,
the first thing you should do
is do dimensional analysis.
And if you do dimensional
analysis, the units of e
squared-- well, this
is easy-- e squared
must be an energy
times a length.
So, this is an energy
Also known as p
squared l, momentum
squared over 2m, 2 times
the mass times the length.
It's useful to put things
in terms of mass, momentum,
and lengths, because
you can cancel them out.
H bar has units of p times l.
And what's the only
other parameter we have?
We have the mass, which
has units of mass.
OK.
And so, from this, we can
build two nice quantities.
The first, is we can build r0.
We can build something
with units of a radius.
And I'm going to choose the
factors of 2 judiciously, h
bar squared over 2me squared--
whoops, e squared-- so,
let's just make sure
this has the right units.
E squared has units of
energy times the length,
but h bar squared
over 2m has units
of p squared l squared
over 2m, so that
has units of energy
times the length squared.
So, length squared over length,
this has units of length,
so this is good.
So, there's a parameter
that has units of length.
And from this, it's
easy to see that we
can build a characteristic
energy by taking e squared
and dividing it by
this length scale.
And so then, the
energy, which I'll
call e0, which is equal
to e squared over r0,
is equal to 2me to the
4th over h bar squared.
So, before we do anything else,
without solving any problems,
we immediately can do
a couple of things.
The first is, if you take the
system and I ask you, look,
what do you expect?
If this is a
quantum mechanical--
a 1d problem in quantum
mechanics-- with a potential,
and we know something about 1D
quantum mechanical problems--
I guess, this guy--
we know something
about 1D quantum
mechanical problems.
Which is that the ground
state has what energy?
Some finite energy.
It doesn't have infinite
negative energy.
It's got some finite energy.
What do you expect to be
roughly the ground state energy
of this system?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURING]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
Roughly minus e0.
That seems like a
pretty good guess.
It's the only dimensional
sensible thing.
Maybe we're off by factors of 2.
But, maybe it's minus e0.
So, that's a good
guess, a first thing,
before we do any calculation.
And if you actually take mu e
to the 4th over h bar squared,
this is off by,
unfortunately, a factor of 4.
This is equal to 4 times
the binding energy, which
is also called the
Rydberg constant.
Wanna make sure I get
my factors of two right.
Yep, I'm off by a factor of 4.
I'm off by a factor
of 4 from what
we'll call the Rydberg
energy, which is 13.6 eV.
And this is observed
binding energy of hydrogen.
So, before we do anything,
before we solve any equation,
we have a fabulous estimate of
the binding energy of hydrogen,
right?
All the work we're
about to do is
gonna be to deal with
this factor of 4, right?
Which, I mean, is
important, but I just
want to emphasize
how much you get just
from doing dimensional analysis.
Immediately upon knowing the
rules of quantum mechanics,
knowing that this is the
equation you should solve,
without ever touching
that equation,
just dimensional analysis
gives you this answer.
OK?
Which is fabulous.
So, with that motivation,
let's solve this problem.
Oh, by the way,
what do you think
r0 is a good approximation to?
Well, it's a length scale.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah!
It's probably something
like the expectation value
of the radius-- or maybe
of the radius squared--
because the expectation value
of the radius is probably 0.
OK, so, let's solve this system.
And at this point, I'm not
gonna actually solve out
the differential
equation in detail.
I'm just gonna tell you
how the solution goes,
because solving it is a sort
of involved undertaking.
And so, here's the first thing,
so we look at this equation.
So, we had this differential
equation-- this guy--
and we want to solve it.
So, think back to the
harmonic oscillator
when we did the brute force
method of solving the hydrogen
system, OK?
When we did the brute force
method-- she sells seashells--
when the brute force method
of solving, what did we do?
We first did, we did
asymptotic analysis.
We extracted the
overall asymptotic form,
at infinity and at
the origin, to get
a nice regular
differential equation that
didn't have any
funny singularities,
and then we did a
series approximation.
OK?
Now, do most
differential equations
have a simple closed
form expression?
A solution?
No, most differential equations
of some, maybe if you're lucky,
it's a special function that
people have studied in detail,
but most don't have a simple
solution like a Gaussian
or a power large, or something.
Most of them just have
some complicated solution.
This is one of those miraculous
differential equations where
we can actually exactly write
down the solution by doing
the series approximation,
having done asymptotic analysis.
So, the first thing when doing
dimensional analysis too, let's
make everything dimensionless.
OK, and it's easy to see what
the right thing to do is.
Take r and make it dimensionless
by pulling out a factor of rho,
or of r0.
So, I'll pick our new variable
is gonna be called rho,
this is dimensionless.
And the second thing is I
want to take the energy,
and I will write it
as minus e0, times
some dimensionless
energy, epsilon.
So, these guys are my
dimensionless variables.
And when you go through and
do that, the equation you get
is minus d rho squared plus l l
plus 1 over rho squared minus 1
over rho plus epsilon
u is equal to 0.
So, the form of this
differential equation
is, OK, it's not
different in any deep way,
but it's a little bit easier.
This is gonna be the easier way
to deal with this, because I
don't have to deal with
any stupid constant.
And so now, let's do
the brute force thing.
Three, asymptotic analysis.
And here, I'm just going
to write down the answers.
And the reason is,
first off, this
is something you should
either do in recitation,
or see-- go through--
on your own,
but this is just the mathematics
of solving a differential
equation.
This is not the important part.
So, when rho goes to infinity,
which terms dominate?
Well, this is not
terribly important.
This is not terribly important.
That term is gonna dominate.
And if we get that d rho squared
plus u, rho goes to infinity,
these two terms dominate.
Well, two derivatives
is a constant.
You know what those
solutions look
like, they look
like exponentials,
with the exponential
being brute--
with the power-- the exponent,
sorry, being root epsilon.
So, u is going to go like e to
the minus square root epsilon
rho.
For normalize-ability,
I picked the minus,
I could've picked the plus,
that would've been divergent.
So, as rho goes to
0, what happens?
Well, as rho goes to 0,
this is insignificant.
And this totally
dominates over this guy.
On the other hand,
if l is equal to 0,
then this is the only
term that survives,
so we'd better make sure
that that behaves gracefully.
As rho goes to 0,
asymptotic analysis
is gonna tell us
that u goes like rho.
Well, two derivatives, we
pulled down a rho squared,
and so two derivatives in
this guy, we pulled down an l,
then an l plus 1.
So, this should go like
rho to the l plus 1.
There's also another term.
So, in the same way that there
were two solutions to this guy
asymptotically-- one growing,
one decreasing-- here,
there's another solution,
which is rho to the minus l.
That also does it, because
we get minus l, then
minus minus l minus 1, which
gives us the plus l l plus 1.
But that is also badly
diversion at the origin,
it goes like 1 over 0 to the l.
That's bad.
So, these are my solutions.
So, this tells us, having
done this in analysis,
we should write that u is
equal to rho to the l plus
1 times e to the
minus root epsilon
rho times some
remaining function,
which I'll call v, little
v. Little v of rho,
and this,
asymptotically, should go
to a constant near the
origin and something that
vanishes slower than an
exponential at infinity.
So then, we take this and
we do our series expansion.
So, we take that
expression, we plug it in.
At that point, all we're doing
is a change of variables.
We plug it in, and we get
a resulting differential
equation.
Rho v prime prime plus 2 1
plus l minus root epsilon rho
v prime plus 1 minus 2 root
epsilon l plus 1 v equals 0.
So, this is the resulting
differential equation
for the little v guy.
And we do a series expansion.
V is equal to sum
over, sum from j
equals 0 to infinity,
of a sub j rho to the j.
Plug this guy in here, just
like in the case of the harmonic
oscillator equation, and
get a series expansion.
Now, OK, let me write
it out this way.
And the series expansion
has a solution,
which is a sub j plus 1.
And this is, actually,
kind of a fun process.
So, if you, you know, like
quick little calculations,
this is a sweet
little calculation
to take this expression.
Plug it in and derive
this recursion relation,
which is root-- or 2 root--
epsilon times j plus l
plus 1 minus 1 over j plus
1 j plus 2 l plus 2 aj.
So, here's our series expansion.
And in order for
this terminate, we
must have that some aj
max plus 1 is equal to 0.
So, one of these guys
must eventually vanish.
And the only thing's that's
changing is little j.
So, what that tells us is
that for some maximum value
of little j, root 2 epsilon
times j maximum plus l plus 1
is equal to minus 1.
But that gives us a
relationship between overall j
max, little l, and the energy.
And if you go through,
what you discover
is that the energy is equal
to 1 over 4 n squared, where
n is equal to j
max plus l plus 1.
And what this tells is
that the energy is labeled
by an integer, n, and an
integer, l, and an integer,
m-- these are from the
spherical harmonics,
and n came from the
series expansion--
and it's equal to minus e0 over
4 n squared, independent of l
and m.
And so, by solving the
differential equation exactly,
which in this case we kind of
amazingly can, what we discover
is that the energy eigenvalues
are, indeed, exactly 1/4 of e0.
And they're spaced with
a 1 over n squared,
which does two things.
Not only does that
explain-- so, let's think
about the consequence of this
very briefly-- not only does
that explain the minus 13.6
eV, not only does that explain
the binding energy of
hydrogen as is observed,
that it does more.
Remember in the very beginning
one of the experimental facts
we wanted to explain
about the universe
was that the spectrum
of light of hydrogen
went like 30 over 4 n squared.
This was the Rydberg relation.
And now we see explicitly.
So, we've solved
for that expansion.
But there's a real puzzle here.
Purely on very
general grounds, we
derived earlier that when you
have a rotationally invariant
potential-- a
central potential--
every energy should
be degenerate,
with degeneracy 2l plus 1.
It can depend on l, but it
must be independent of m.
But here, we've
discovered-- first off,
we've fit a nice bit
of experimental data,
but we've discovered the
energy is, in fact, not just
independent of m, but it's
independent of l, too.
Why?
What symmetry is explaining
this extra degeneracy?
We'll pick that up next time.